foreign
how did he lose trust with you he likes
to tell half truths and I mean he likes
a lie I was gonna say your your language
is somebody who is so gaslit like you've
got third degree burns
[Music]
what is up
this is John with the Dr John deloney
show so grateful that you joined us and
given us your most precious resource
your time to the greatest mental health
in marriage and parenting podcast that's
ever existed and we also talk about
education and politics whatever else you
want to talk about so glad that you're
here please
um a way you can support this show by
literally doing virtually nothing but
one little thing is to just hit the
Subscribe button if you're watching us
on YouTube or listen on podcast and send
this to a friend and if you want to be
crazy
um leave a five-star review I'm so
grateful it helps put this show in the
hands and ears of other people and
um there is no greater uh support than
word of mouth so thank you so so much
for doing that and hey if you've been
riding with us for a long time I got
killer news so
um when does this show come out Kelly
okay November 2nd all right so when you
get this
these will have just be out but I just
got these dropped on my desk these are
the newest
questions for humans and here's what we
got we we got second edition questions
for humans friends second edition
questions for couples
whoa we have second edition parents and
kids my kids and I and my wife did those
last night at dinner and they were a
blast and just for a short time I've
decided to I don't usually try to be a
hero I am this time we're saving your
Christmas and your Thanksgiving so we've
created
um New Year's and Christmas cards that
you can take on the holidays and they do
say like we don't have a Thanksgiving
one per se but these are two holiday
packs that you can take with you on
holidays when you're gonna be staring at
your mother-in-law and you don't know
what to say and she doesn't want to hear
what you have to say anyway now y'all
can use the cards and have a great
holiday season there's no coveted
conversations there's no Trump or Biden
conversation questions there's none of
it
it's just human interaction human 101 go
to John delaney.com and you can get the
new questions for humans you can
probably buy them in some kind of wild
bundle or something like that
um but thank you for supporting it and
thank you for making your families and
your relationships stronger it's awesome
all right let's go to Lee and in Kansas
City what's up Leanne
hey how's it going I'm good how are you
I'm doing well thanks for taking my call
of course what's up
so
um I bottom line is yeah just say it
whatever it is just say it
I I don't trust my husband and I don't I
don't know how to trust him
okay how did he lose trust with you
so
he likes to tell
half truths and intentionally I mean he
likes to lie I was gonna say your your
language is somebody who is so gaslit
like you've got third degree burns
he tells after he's a liar let's start
with that okay keep going yeah what does
he lie about I mean like small things
but also really big things like to him
it's small but like two that we can't
make it to
um somebody's birthday party and he
thinks he needs to come up with like an
elaborate really deep reason why we
don't need to be there and I'm like we
we're not going because whatever I mean
we don't want to go for a reason right
we don't want to go or or not that but
he'll do that and then he will lie about
big things too like
I mean I could think of a million things
but like
okay
um we had to get rid of a cat that we
had okay and this is this feels so dumb
saying this because this is how dumb the
situation is but we had to get rid of
this cat because he wasn't taking care
of it when I was gone which again sounds
dumb but the reason he told everybody
else was because this cat got sick and
um we couldn't take care of it anymore
and that just wasn't the reason and I'm
like you you were you were being
irresponsible
that's why we had to get rid of it it's
like clearly he's uncomfortable with
these things but after so long I I just
can't trust him and then smaller things
like getting into
onto the field at football games like he
thinks that's so great but he's like
he's lying about it by printing off fake
passes
as a grown man to get onto the field at
a football game and I just find it so
childish and embarrassing and after now
10 years of marriage like I
all those small eyes build up over time
I just
I don't trust them uh what else does
so I hear you 100 percent
there's something else what is it
I
I don't I don't know like like there's
something sitting but has he cheated on
you
no
I mean there was there was a long period
of time where he just wouldn't have sex
with me and it hurts so much and he just
kept saying it was because he you know
medication or
um
yeah mostly just medication or he was
like I think I'm asexual and I'm like
what that doesn't make any sense and I
will like the entire time
for like this three year period I really
I just questioned it three years
three years
wow
and
I do you all share your money
yes
well I mean
yes but there's
um there's money that I don't be fully I
guess
so here's the deal
it happens
you've run into an old college friend
who used to be big and they lost a bunch
of weight you haven't seen them in a few
years and it's like whoa it looks it's
so dramatic
and they it feels so good but for them
they know it's dramatic they see the
number on the scale but to them it
happened every day
just like a quarter of a pound here half
of a pound here gain a pound back lose
one and a half pounds right and that
happened over the period of a couple of
years and so it's very gradual
and suddenly they're a totally different
person when you walk in right
yeah
what's happened over the last 10 years
is
you have gradually
grain by grain of sand lost your footing
on reality
your husband lies about everything
and he's lying about big stuff too and
you know it
and my guess is not only is he great at
lying and cutting corners and cheating
he's living in an ALT reality right he
lives in a world that the rules don't
apply to him reality doesn't apply to
him and everyone else is stupider than
me
from the guy the poor volunteer at the
high school football game to my boss to
the people who took my cat to my wife
they're all dumber than me I'm running a
scam on all of them
and what happens when that happens over
time without the the big bludgeon of you
found pictures of him with somebody else
right there's that
but that's not what happened here this
was just Pebble by Pebble by Pebble and
suddenly over time you the person you
trust the least is Leanne
you think you're crazy
you're not crazy
you're not crazy
and I'm like
the heartbreaking thing here is
um
you've been being dragged underwater for
a long time and you keep wondering why
you can't find your footing and so it's
your fault
yeah so here's the here's the path out
and it's not a pleasant one okay
okay it's sitting with somebody who you
know and love and trust and who actually
knows this dude knows the whole story
knows everything because because my I I
almost guarantee in the in the core of
my being I know
that if you and I sat here and peeled
back the layers on this there is some
bad stuff
yeah
is that fair
yeah
this type of behavior in this type of
pattern hasn't happened this long
without there being some big stuff that
you simply put hardwood floors over
because you couldn't bear to look at it
or see or feel it and so this sits with
you sitting with somebody else if you
don't have a close close friend that
knows everything or a sister or a cousin
that knows everything you go get a
counselor but you've got to come up with
your no more list
and you're gonna have to have an or else
okay
okay
um there has to be a Reckoning with
coming clean here
you're you're dangerously close to
losing yourself for good and I don't
want that for you yeah and what I mean
by that is you prop your feet up and you
drop your shoulders and you say the the
the the scariest words in the English
language
it is what it is
and then this just becomes your reality
okay you know what I mean and hey you're
a grown up you can choose that
I wouldn't wish that on my worst enemy
is what it is
but you can choose that moving forward
you can decide that's what it's going to
be
I hope you don't
I hope you don't
I hope you look in the mirror when we
get off this phone and you say I'm worth
way the hell more than this
and I hope you get off the phone you
look in the mirror and say I deserve to
be told the truth I'd be deserved to not
cheated on I deserve to not be married
to some immature [ __ ] who's hiding
money from me who's hiding relationship
stuff who's hiding deep secrets about
his own sexuality maybe I don't know
what he's hiding but it's clearly a deep
well that you haven't been invited to
and you're his wife
and you get invited to those things by
virtue of marriage
so he can come clean
[Music]
he can stop his lot addiction to
dishonesty his addiction to thinking
he's better than everybody in his world
that everybody around him is stupid
he can quit that
or he opts out of your relationship
because you're worth more than this
and you know that I don't ever I've got
a rule about saying you should leave
but it's time for real real hard
boundaries in your relationship because
you're worth more than this leading way
way more we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org Equal Housing lender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
all right we are back hey I gave Leanne
a copy during the break of own your past
change your future
to book
um number one bestseller about man I
gotta own what happened I gotta own the
life that I have stumbled into or I've
allowed to be created or I was dragged
into or shoved into I gotta own it and
then I've got to ask myself what do I do
next and how do I get out right how do I
make changes and so it sent that along
to her too
um I have a visceral response to that
type of lying and dishonesty
whoo all right we're gonna go on to the
next call let's go to Alex in Seymour
what's up Alex
Hey Brother John how are you partying
dude what about you
all right I think some would call it a
party but I'm lying to you man I'm at
work man I'm at work uh well I'm not
really at work I'm running a scam here
called a podcast but it's cool so what's
up with you man
uh not a whole lot uh well actually no
that's a lie myself uh we've got a lot
going on uh
to the question and see if uh where we
go from there cool uh I work a uh normal
uh full-time job okay and I'm also
trying to get our small little business
off the ground and in the process I'm
trying to figure out how to do that get
the proper attention to my wife and
two-year-old
and then give enough attention to the
business so that it keeps making
progress keep hammering down on debt
because we're doing that plan as well
and really just not try to leave
everything behind me just in ashes
it seems like what's happening so some
yeah something's happened that
precipitated this call what is it
uh man I just feel fried and then I I
I'm trying to like I said I'm trying to
get the business going the goal is to
make this a full-time gig and what's
your current day job
I'm an engineer okay and what's the
business you're trying to crank up
uh we're actually a small scale farming
that's turned into a larger scale
farming and I find a lot of heavier
black and white huh all right no I I
can't imagine how
how what a gift it is to go from being
an engineer and that pressure and that's
all the spreadsheets and all of the
all the stuff right and then heading out
to the farm
what kind of farming are you doing
well the day of produce we did I think
this year we did somewhere around four
acres of produce okay
hundreds of meat birds
uh thousands of uh dozens of eggs I
think 2 200 dozen eggs is what we can do
a year and uh
uh also added honeybees so because why
not why not Yeah well yeah why not
um is that are you making money on that
are you still dumping money into it
actually I am in the positive uh it's
not much
so I'm trying to use the day job to uh
you know uh get the big equipment and
stuff like that and uh funded that away
uh when I you know ideally stepped into
it full time that I don't have to keep
uh you know buying equipment and that a
way that hopefully the first full-time
year is much more profitable
um so yeah there's a few thousand bucks
being made not much but there's a lot of
also investment in there as well so if I
were to somehow be able to have that you
know furnished to me then it would be
much more impressive but right now it's
it's not very impressive which I didn't
really expect
I need to oh go ahead I was gonna say uh
here's the bottom line is you've got a
lot going on man a lot
and I am all about
all about like right now I'm writing
another book
uh this is my busy season when I'm on
the road all over the place last week I
was in three states okay
um I got this show co-host the Ramsey
show I've got other media that I mean
it's it's Madness and three weeks ago I
sat down with my wife and we mapped out
in the next three months they're gonna
be wild
and maybe the next four months it's
gonna be Madness I canceled some family
plans sent a email out to all of my
family and said we're not hosting
holidays this year it's just not it's
going to be too maddening
um so what I tell you that to tell you
man sometimes with work and with little
kids which I got two
um
and being married trying to hold that
all together they're seasons of chaos
and that's completely okay
it's when everybody knows this chaos is
coming this chaos is here here's how
we're going to navigate it we're all on
the same page we're checking in my wife
and I check in once a week if not twice
a week where are we where are we where
are we and it's got an end date to it
and it sounds like I'm gonna I'm just
gonna be honest with you how old are you
just turned 30. okay oh man
here's what you are reminding me of tell
me if I'm off
I'm a full-time College administrator
um
the executive leadership team student
affairs division
and then I have a little boy and he
turns 18 months and I realize I don't
know how to do this because every time I
hold him he cries for Mom and I don't
know how to like I play trucks and then
I'm so bored within 38 seconds I want to
take that truck and stab it into my
eyeball and my wife has changed I've
changed I don't know what to do
but I'm good at my job
and so I start doubling down a little
bit more and a little bit more and then
I took on a full-time faculty role on
top of my full-time administrative role
and then I took another part-time job
out of the president's office working on
a special project
and all of that in my head was this idea
that I'm working towards This Magic
Moment that I'm Gonna Be Free
and I'm going to achieve my way towards
um I'm gonna over achieve at work to
make up for I don't really know what the
crap I'm doing in my house
foreign
or am I wrong
yeah I mean a lot of that rings with me
uh and and now I mean the end of this
the season now for us is
largely just sales
um the last round of birds are done the
bees are up for the winter obviously
produces done
um and uh I mean we just kind of barely
scratched I don't even know if we've
made it
crawled across the Finish Line this year
just just barely hanging on and the uh
you know I walked through the day
struggling in the day job thinking about
all the things I got and it just feels
like somebody's standing on me yeah and
I I don't know how
uh
I mean I just want to just kind of like
sit in my burning house and and you know
let it
fall in but hey at least it's warm yeah
exactly exactly like there's comfort in
the chaos I don't
because hey if when there's comfort in
the chaos you get to avoid reality
because when you're putting out fires or
you're dodging the smoke you actually
feel like you're accomplishing something
that you don't feel like when you're
just sitting by your wife holding her
hand
or that you're sitting down on all fours
rolling a ball back and forth with a
two-year-old that going
and then randomly just says I hate you
right
at least when the house is on fire you
got something to do
the problem is the house is on fire
yeah and I try to bring him with me
sometimes I know hey hey you're a good
dad man
you're a good dad
it's just too much right now it's too
much
so my question for you would be is now
the time to have 22 000 million dozen
eggs
it is now this time to be like you know
what else we should do we should add
bees let's do bees and you know what I
know I know you've already thought about
bringing goats or sheep or cows on next
year
well if we find the property I knew it
see sucker listen you're gonna busy
yourself to death
yeah you you talk about like diseases of
Despair and I feel the I think it's just
a lonely place and it almost feels like
the heart just like hey that that last
day was so busy you just took three of
three days away from me I mean it just
um
yeah yeah you know when's the last time
you took a break man
uh
uh oh let me ask you let me ask you a
different way how's your marriage
uh so yesterday was actually our
anniversary
we uh quote unquote celebrated with
carryout and hanging out not really
having really anything significant about
it
and that was even more bothersome
so when I ask you the question you did a
great job hanging in there with me you
did a great job evading it but when I
ask you how's your marriage the answer
the truthful answer is not well right
or
not what you had envisioned it would be
yeah
um do you hate your engineering job
oh I hate it
okay I mean until it's the golden
handcuffs feeling yeah
I got that I've been there I've totally
been there I got it
I don't want to uh
uh it seems selfish if I if I were to
just say you know what throwing all my
cards in on this we've
we've uh you know proven we can make
some money if I put more time in it
we'll make some more money and
but if that were to fail I don't know if
I would it just feels incredibly selfish
in the shame that would follow that I
just can't even imagine here's what's
here's what's more shameful if you ask
me
there's no shame in making a calculated
risk and going for it
because if you take a calculated risk
not an idiotic risk not a moronic risk
but one with a spreadsheet and some
wisdom and some people who've done this
before and sit down and chart it out
with you
not one that's going to take on a whole
bunch of debt and it's going to put you
and your family the livelihood at risk
but a calculated risk that can pay off
significantly for your family is good
and a calculated risk that could pay off
that fails is extraordinarily good for
your kids because they get to watch
their dad got in a ring and took a swing
at the biggest guy in there and he got
knocked down and then they get to see
what happens when you get knocked down
and you get back up
so that's not the issue I think more
shameful
is
living a life of quiet desperation and
teaching your son this is what manhood
is
I think more shameful is sacrificing
your marriage to the altar of busy
yeah
right or trading dragging feels like it
it does
I would rather and this is going to
sound crazy and here's how radical I'm
suggesting I'd rather see you sell the
farm tomorrow
to put up for sale
and spend three years in your
engineering job with a with an idea that
in 36 months I'm out of here I have no
debt I've put my family in a position
where we got six to nine months to a
year's salary so we can jump off this
thing and do something different
right now you're spreading yourself so
thin
or I'd rather you hire somebody to run
the farm for the next 24 months keep it
hire somebody so that you're not having
to work a full-time engineering job and
go out and do this and you're going to
lose money
but you're building right now
yeah and nobody you you your mind your
training you could create a plan
infinitely better than what I could draw
up with my Humanity psychology
background
I'd be wanting to think about everything
you know how to actually chart it out on
a piece of paper and say I'm gonna start
here and by this date I'm gonna have
this much money I'm gonna owe this many
people zero dollars
I'm gonna be ready to make a move then
and then you sit down with your wife and
say we have 24 more months
how can we carve out the greatest life
worth living in those 24 months while I
put extra work on top of extra work on
top of extra work into the steel
because here's what I'm wondering I'm
wondering if you hate engineering it's
totally fair and you created an Exit
Plan
and you slowly started building your
exit strategy and now you're halfway in
it you don't like it either
oh uh I should mention I mean this is
year three okay so it's not like
yesterday or no no I know I know but is
it possible that you're year three and
you're like oh gosh this is a lot a lot
a lot a lot of work
oh I I I'm totally aware of the the work
you know I really do truly find a lot of
Joy when somebody comes back after they
buy uh you know say a chicken breast and
and throw them and say man those were
freaking awesome I don't know how you
raise those birds but it was fantastic
or the honey with this or that or the
other I mean it's just an awesome High
absolutely it really I do feel like I'm
really serving somebody the best way
that I know how I think my wife enjoys
you know that part of it as well she
certainly doesn't like to get her hands
dirty as much as I do but
your whole voice change is talking about
this
it's quite yeah I mean your whole voice
changes
so let's do this almost spiritual to me
yes so let's do this let's stop screwing
around with the other stuff
you can't you can't keep no no
with the
go into engineering every day and hating
it
farming all hours of the night not being
present with my wife not learning the
skills of how to be a husband to
somebody who's
um
got a kid not learning the new skills on
how to be a present father you may not
have got that from your old man
or you may have got a great old man but
just times have changed and you got to
learn some new skills
right now you're trying to do all these
things at the same time and it's not
going to work
so either come up with a scorched Earth
plan financially in your home we are
going to not spend a single penny beyond
what it takes to survive for the next
six months because I've got to get out
of this engineering job
and I'm going to go Full Tilt into this
farming deal if we can afford it we can
make it
and if we do the math and we realize we
can't make it we'd have to have another
billion eggs or another whatever
then we're gonna figure something else
out
and by the way the other night me and
Ben Hill and several others played in a
rock band it was so incredible so fun
there was thousand two thousand people
out there screaming yelling going
bananas
it was a spiritual moment for me
if you ask my 18 year old self it's what
I was put on Earth to do to be in a
metal band
and I also had to come to terms with it
doesn't pay my bills
and it breaks my heart and it makes me
sad because I would love to do that as
much as I love this job I would love to
be a full-time Rock and roller it's not
gonna happen
I'm not that good
and so instead of trying to do it for a
living I do it in pockets and I do it
regularly and I do it by myself
sometimes and I do with a group
sometimes and if there's a big show I'll
throw my name in the ring
but I've turned it into a hobby instead
of a way of being right
but if nothing else you hear
this may not be the season four you fill
in the blank you're gonna have to take a
break from something
because this can't continue I can hear
it in your voice
last thing is
you need to go talk to a a grown man
ahead of you a couple of men who are
wise who've been who are 10 years ahead
of you in the farming game five years
ahead of you in engineering game who
have had kids who are 10 years old and 8
years old who are ahead of you
because right now it feels like you're
drowning and you're probably not
drowning like you think you are but it
feels like it because all the feelings
are new
that's why Community is so important get
some men in your life who've got some
wisdom who are a little bit ahead of you
down the road okay hang on the line I'm
gonna send you a copy of all your past
change your future too and I want you to
read it and think about this other stuff
because there's me you and I could talk
for a long time I know it
um I want you to get to the bottom of
the
you've accepted
and be about building something new
we'll be right back
hey guys deloney here and I've got a
word from our sponsor whoop if you've
listened to the show for any length of
time you know I'm a major nerd about
Fitness sleep mental health and building
healthier life habits and let's just say
this whoop makes my nerd heart so happy
one reason I love whoop is that it's not
like all the other fitness trackers that
mix in a watch in laser lights and
smiley faces and a million notifications
and reminders that you you need to get
your steps in no whoop is a fitness
wearable that actually looks cool and
it's comfortable and it gives you data
that really matters it breaks down your
recovery your sleep and your daily
strain into a format that's easy to
interpret and some days I wake up in the
green and this tells me that I'm ready
to go attack the day and other days I
wake up in the red and I know that I
gotta take it easy and I can look back
in time and see how I got there if
you're working to be intentional and
build healthier habits whoop can help
you get there start keeping an eye on
your health and wellness at a deeper
level go to whoop dot com that's
w-h-o-o-p.com and use promo code deloni
to get 10 off your order today
all right we are back let's go to
Alexandra in sewick's Falls in Sioux
Falls South Dakota what's up Alexandra
nothing much how are you doing Dr John
good you all having fun
you know it's like 50 some degrees here
today so no maybe not quite as much fun
as I had hoped we'd have that's like the
depths of winter here in Nashville very
cool
so what's up can I jump right in with my
question let's do it
okay
so I typed it out so I wouldn't get too
tongue-tied perfect
um I'll go ahead
um how do I connect with my father who
I'm starting to resent
um a little bit of backstory so my dad
has drug-induced schizophrenia he's had
it since he was in his 20s
um and he had my sister and I when he
was 28 and 29.
my parents divorced shortly after that
and he went to jail for a little while I
was six months old and my sister was a
year and a half
um growing up my dad lived with my
great-grandmother and we would go see
him at her house during this time he
cycled every three to five years so when
this would happen we would go a little
while without seeing him and we were
told that he was Ill not really
explaining anything else
um and then once he was doing better
we'd go back and see him like nothing
happened
I was about 16 when somebody finally
explained it to me that it was a mental
illness and explained to me a little bit
about what schizophrenia was and why we
were allowed around him at that time
um and so at 19 he had
he went off of his medication so he
cycled and
at that point I guess my family had kind
of decided that my sister and I were old
enough to figure it out by ourselves
um and with
literally no guidance at all
um we were able to help him get into
um checked into the ER because at 19 I
have no idea how to handle a mental
illness at all and so we went to the ER
because that was
what I guess we were supposed to do
um and so we got a mistake eval and then
got him put into a
I don't a behavioral health unit sure
where they got him back on his
medication and he got out a couple days
later and we went and got him brought
him back to my grandmother's house and
that's kind of how it's been
um ever since then we moved him up to
Sioux Falls he used to live in Iowa uh
we moved him up to Sioux Falls because
we thought maybe him being closer to us
and like seeing us more would be helpful
to him
um he's actually started the cycle now
every like couple months every two to
three months so he goes off of his
medication for two to three months
um and he hides it super well he doesn't
talk about it very often and he hates
whenever we bring it up and so usually
we just try not to
um and then we notice things we start
getting text messages about like needing
to run and hide and how people are after
him
um and then
it takes us about a month or so to
convince him to go back to behavioral
health
um get them checked in try to get them
back on track there is a program here
that you go to right after that right
after being in the hospital
and he never stays on it and so he's
good for about two to three months and
then we just start over again okay okay
listen listen listen listen
I'm hoping somebody's told you
everything I'm about to tell you okay
is that cool
yeah
this isn't the way this is supposed to
be
foreign
you deserved a dad who was fully present
with you who held you like the princess
you were because you were his baby girl
and who dedicated his life to making
sure your life was good
and you deserved a dad who was going to
hold you
and every day despite your protests tell
you that you were beautiful and that he
loved you
and despite your protest he was going to
look you in the eye and say I'm so glad
that of all the crazy people in the
world God picked me to be your dad
foreign that's how it's supposed to be
and I'm sorry that you didn't get that
but I need you to hear I need you to
hear this Direct
[Music]
the dad you missed growing up was not
your fault
the dead you missed growing up was
because he was sick not you and you have
spent a long long time trying to bridge
that Gap to a relationship back to him
because your little six month old and
seven-year-old and 12 year old and 19
year old body is trying to tell you
somehow this is your fault
if you would just fill in the blank move
him closer pay more closer attention to
his meds maybe he moves in all of this
language that Cycles to your head over
and over is that somehow you need to be
doing something different and the dead
can be okay
and that's not true
goodness
am I wrong no you're not
okay I want you to do me a huge favor I
want you to take as deep a breath as you
possibly can and hold it
three two let it out and I want you to
drop your shoulders all the way down
okay
I could feel them creeping up to your
ears
okay
schizophrenia is the devil
because it takes the people that we love
away from us
and they're there in body
and they look at us and you've been with
your dad when he's off his meds when
he's off cycle
and he's looking right at you but he
doesn't see you you know what I mean
yeah absolutely it's terrifying isn't it
the Temptation should we go from here
you're not gonna like what I have to say
okay and I want you to know if you hang
up this phone you say that guy sucks I'm
totally okay with that okay my promise
is I'm just never gonna not tell you the
truth okay I also know that it's easy
for me to say what I'm about to say
because I don't have this challenge in
my house
and I can't honestly say how I would
respond if I was in your same boat okay
but you cannot be the person responsible
for keeping your dad well
you can't
you can't check up on him every 30
minutes and make sure he's on his meds
you can't make sure that when he stops
taking his meds that he doesn't have
access to phones and stuff because he's
gonna go fill in the blank fill in the
blank fill in the blank you cannot make
your dad be healthy and whole and I'm so
sorry
in a season when he is on meds
and he's it sounds like he levels out is
that fair
yeah okay
when he levels out
there has to be some sort of
conversation which is Dad if you get off
of your medication
you are making a choice to no longer be
in my life and my sister's life
and I miss you and I want you in our
life and I hope that you will never make
that choice
but when he's on his meds he understands
that his brain's not telling him the
truth
does he
um
um okay okay it just turns the turns the
volume of the alarms down a little bit
so this is the thing that I get a little
bit confused about
um he was discharged from the military
when he was 18 I think and what they had
told him was that he had multiple
personality disorder or something like
that and then he got the diagnosis of
schizophrenia
and the thing that I don't understand is
normally like you said medication turns
the volumes down
um he actually liked being off of his
mess like he oh dude yes I've never met
a schizophrenic person that's not true
maybe one who enjoyed being on their
medication
foreign
because there's this impending sense
that
um it's like being in a room full of
crowded people with headphones on you
know they're talking
and they might be talking about me
but I'm wearing headphones because I
can't take the volume
you get that you know that that how that
would just gnaw at you you know I know
they're talking and I wonder what
they're saying but I do know this if I
listen to what they're saying I go
insane
I hurt myself and other people
and so my path forward is one of two
choices
being like sticking my head into the
fire or choosing to not listen to what's
going on in the world around me
and so the tension is there I've met one
person who enjoyed being was able to
um
preferred being in relationship then
then
being on the inside of this radical
information they had right
but that's a and I don't know what kind
of I don't know enough about the
neurophysiology of schizophrenia and the
schizotypal disorders and all the
different little nuances of that my
guess is their brain lesions were a
little bit different are their brain
chemistry is a little bit different
um no it's a it's a choice it's a battle
it's a war because you feel this
impending sense of dude they're coming
and you are choosing not to look that's
what that feels like
and yes so what you're suggesting
is that when he's off of this medication
oh oh go ahead go ahead I cut you off go
ahead
wood chip with my sister and I
um but when he chooses to be on it and
that's the other thing is
if
we've tried that before where like
if he's off of his medication we're
still talking to him but we're not
pushing him to go
get evaluated we're not pushing him to
go to the hospital and so I mean nobody
is then
it just doesn't happen and then so this
happened two weeks ago he disappeared
for seven days left his phone left his
car left everything just gone dropped
off the face of the planet
um and I filed a missing person's report
on him and he showed up seven days later
that he was living in the woods
he enjoyed it out there but he came back
because he needed his phone can I tell
you it sounds like this is escalating
yeah
I just at some point at some point you
go sit down
um
with the local care services and or
whatever go back to the the hospital you
had him admitted to originally
and ask about the procedure in your
particular state for an involuntary
committal
because it sounds like he is fast on a
path to not being able to take care of
himself
and you have to recognize your
limitations you do not have the ability
to deal with the level of psychosis your
father has
okay and that's a powerless feeling
we've gone through that four times this
year okay we've done this this
involuntary commitment okay you just
keep cycling and so how many how many
times do you no I would ask for I would
I would ask for what does a court order
look like to make this a permanent
residency
the hospital no no a long-term care
Treatment Center
uh for somebody with psychosis who's
unable to care for themselves
and if he's a threat to himself or
others there's a possibility that you
can get him committed
long term
and I would pursue that if I'm in your
exact shoes because here's the deal you
can't solve this you can't fix it
right and it sounds like if he's
continuing to get off his meds and he's
cycling more and more and faster and
faster and now he's disappearing for two
days and now it turns into seven days
and now it turns into see what I'm
saying this is on a trajectory that is I
don't like
and you and you are gonna have you and
your sister are gonna have to fight the
impulse to blame yourself for the
trajectory because it's not your fault
great your dad's not doing well
in fact the greatest gift you could give
your dad is for you to be whole
and when he's on his meds
and he has a conversation with you those
rare conversations where everything's
light everything he can maybe make some
jokes he remembers the old days
you think to yourself there he is there
he is there's the real him I can go get
him
I can go get him there
and unfortunately that's not their whole
real him because the whole real him is
very very sick
and it's easy to live in a fantasy and
even when he's cycled off and you
continue to talk to him and you continue
to talk to him and you continue to talk
to him
you're just heading down a bottomless
pit with somebody
and I know it's your dad and I I know
it's so hard I know it's so hard
especially given the years of abuse you
suffered
but the wise mature thing here is to
step back take 10 Paces back and put
your hands up and say I don't have the
expertise
to heal my dad
I don't have the expertise or the
financial wherewithal or even the
ability to continue to prop my father up
for 5 10 15 20 years however long this
is going to go and this is starting to
cycle faster and faster and faster and
he's going to end up
um
in a hurting himself or somebody else
so it's time for me to call in folks who
could care for him long term
and let's go down that road and see what
that's going to look like I don't know
what that looks like in Sioux Falls my
guess is they've got some significant
resource opportunities there but that's
where I would go
remember remember
it's not your fault
it's not
fault
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we're back as we wrap up
today's show the song of the day
throwback to caller number one
from the great Fleetwood Mac
song is little lies and it goes like
this
If I Could Turn the Page in time and I'd
rearrange just a day or two close my
close my close my eyes but I couldn't
find a way so I'll settle for one day to
believe in you tell me
tell me lies tell me lies tell me Sweet
Little Lies oh no you can't disguise
tell me lies tell me Sweet Little Lies
although I'm not making plans I hope
that you understand there's a reason why
close your eyes no more broken hearts
we're better off apart let's give it a
try tell me tell me
tell me lies tell me Sweet Little Lies
don't don't lie don't lie tell the truth
we'll be right back
or I will be right back I'll see you
soon one of those things see you later
[Music]